on the afternoon of Thanksgiving 1962 I
decided to start project mine and the
next day I had an appointment with the
Provost Charlie towns and I told him
what I had in mind and I said well think
about them let me know and he said oh no
go ahead so young caused by that during
the weekend I got a little bit more
random to page then on Monday I
distributed around MIT and on Tuesday I
went to say the president just Latin and
the only question that he had where are
you gonna do it and by that time I had
done some homework and find out that in
the new building that was being built in
technology square so there was a space
on Thursday Lickliter was supposed to
come to MIT for something else so
everybody got together in the
president's office we shook hands and
that was it oh wow exactly one week
there were no computer scientists after
all because nobody had a computer
science program yet so everybody was a
mathematician a physicist
an electrical engineer a dropout we had
them all but they had skipped the analog
age every one of them was peculiar and
different and unusual and maybe artistic
and but whatever they wanted to do they
would get done and project that had to
be done was they was whatever was the
right thing to do because I discovered
the right path you know and I like that
that's a the way science ought to be
there's been an initial surge to try to
do something about time sharing so I
decided to initiate a basically a quick
hack by creating a time sharing system
using the IBM 709 but by just basically
using
the mechanisms that have been tacked on
to the 709 so the operating system could
begin to function as as a time-sharing
system we we basically took a very quick
cut and creating what came to be called
the compatible time sharing system the
hackers worked on their computers but
there was all the CTS s and the multix
folks Corbett oh and and you know
there's the hackers felt like by golly
we gotta be there was to do better than
they did so our corporate O's initial
operating system is called C TSS and so
they called Aires ideas
CTS senses compatible time sharing
system in IPS was the incompatible time
sharing system and that created a
culture of among the hackers which was
really hard to beat there was wonderful
family several years afterwards when
project Mac was really become a
laboratory I tried to change the name
the administration won't let me
laboratory was a piece of a department
don't research into an established area
and computer science was not the
question regarde there's an established
area and one of the things we did
towards the beginning project Mac was we
decided we had to revise revamp and redo
the file system that created different
new unknown atmosphere in project work
that is the computer system became a
property of the people and this district
was a phenomenon that we didn't expect
people tried created a community and
people started writing program for other
people to use which was a new thing
we had a big memory you know the whole
megabyte of RAM in my pocket
is 10,000 times as much RAM as Joel has
the biggest computer we had them but we
were on the on the leading edge saying
we need that sort of thing and that
became the standard sort of thing
and yeah I don't think if we weren't
doing that that wouldn't have happened I
mean if we all knew about Moore's law
and I sort of believed it but I can't
further the life of me figure out why I
couldn't have anticipated what's
happened I just didn't and I don't know
why that was myopia or or what but you
know it's also logical when you look
backwards and it it seems to happen just
on schedule but yeah but why why didn't
we predict it I don't know well I think
the kinds of things we big we did back
then have become a part of mainstream
computer science and as they become more
important they've become less
conspicuous okay people were shocked I
mean there were two things one was the
idea that out of a typewriter you could
control a computer it is this is this
was basically unthinkable for many
people and and then the power inherent
to the thing what you could do
where was it just the different world
that people were enchanted
you